[Musique]
l'homophobie n'a de sas et c'est pour
beaucoup d'abilio rance et de
l'ignorance et un manque de connaissance
de l'autre il faut aller vers l'autre il
faut le comprendre parce qu'à une vie à
part il n'y a pas qu'une seule existence
y a pas qu'une seule façon de vie via
pas qu'une seule façon nous sommes tous
différents donc il ya bien une raison
donc il n'y a pas qu'une seule vérité
donc le fait de vouloir imposer une
vérité une croyance minois dijon ça
devient presque la dictature je pense
que le cocon familial est très important
donc j'ai la chance d'avoir une mère et
un père adoptif qui m'ont forgé dans
l'excellence dans la culture dans
l'amont de soi des grands parents
j'étais lever aussi par mes grands
parents donc vraiment une famille
aimante je pense que quand on s'aime on
a des choses à offrir aux deux autres on
a on peut être dans le partage et la
compréhension la rencontre de l'autre et
c'est ce que je je
je remercierai énormément ma famille
c'est de m'accepter tel que je suis
parce que je ne sais pas on ne choisit
pas son orientation sexuelle ou son état
d'esprit je pense qu'on sait inné et
puis après on peut que se construit on
peut construire son identité en plus
construit son parcours de vie mais nous
sommes uniques et on est content
ainsi le jour où j'ai compris que je
vivais pour moi et que c'était ma vie
que je construisais que c'était ma quête
du bonheur que je menais un bain je me
suis détaché de là l'importance de 2 du
jugement j'ai compris que ma liberté
pouvait être une frustration pour
certains mais ma liberté gilles acquise
je me suis je me la suis imposé donc
nous sommes maîtres de notre destin donc
après ce que vont subir une société on
veut être acteur de sa vie après ce sont
des questions qu'il faut se poser mais
c'est un cheminement